olá como as pessoas vão interagir com as
cidades
pense um pouco comigo aqui nessa
história
nos últimos anos eu tenho refletido
muito sobre essa pergunta
e pra mim a primeira coisa que a gente
tem que fazer antes de pensar no futuro
das cidades é tentar entender como a
gente pode mudar o nosso modelo de
consumo
eu acredito que é fundamental a gente
rever a forma como a gente está
consumindo no mundo a nossa sociedade
toda aconteceu uma história comigo há
uns dois ou três anos que me marcou
muito que me doeu muito
eu estava tomando uma cerveja com um
amigo que estava comemorando a sua
aposentadoria
ele está feliz pra caramba porque aos 60
e poucos anos ele finalmente a começar a
viver isso me marcou muito está feliz
com os filhos estavam assumindo os
negócios e tal
isso me deu muito porque eu sempre me
inspirei muito nele continua me
inspirando mas naquele momento eu
percebi que eu não queria ser rico
eu não queria ter uma vida é essa em que
você só começa a viver os 60 eu quero
continuar vivendo todos os meus dias
como eu faço hoje ea partir desse
momento definir a minha primeira meta na
vida
a partir daquele momento que seria não
deixar um real sequer de herança para os
meus filhos trabalham em outro e eu já
vejo acendê-la moribundo por favor da
aqmi de minha última cerveja porque eu
acredito que o legado que a gente tem
que deixar para os nossos filhos não é o
dinheiro não era essa não é o patrimônio
e sim a capacidade de olhar para o mundo
entender que ele é grande e cheio de
oportunidades ea capacidade de olhar
para o vizinho que está do seu lado com
problemas precisando de ajuda que você
tem que estender a mão para ele se ele
estiver em tudo isso eles vão ser
capazes de ser o que quiserem na vida
inclusive ricos se essa for a time deles
não sou eu que vou fazer com que os três
sejam ricos e pra mim tem uma
característica muito importante nesse
processo de mudança de comportamento que
foi abrir mão do carro também aconteceu
mais ou menos por aí há 12 anos
eu sempre sonhei em pilotar uma ferrari
e só depois que eu deixei de pegar fogo
descobri que eu não queria ter uma
ferrari eu queria de pilotar um e é
muito fácil é só você ir para a itália
gasta uma grana aí e passa uma semana
votando 300 quilos por ano na ferrari
sem precisar comprar um refletir um
pouco sobre isso
e mais quando chegar em casa hoje dei
uma olhada na casa de vocês e vejo a
contar de coisas que vocês compraram que
vocês têm que usar um pouquinho mais
vezes ou até que nunca usaram e tem um
cara que eu tenho acompanhado o que é
super bacana chamado jeremy rifkin que
ele tem uma teoria muito legal ele disse
que no futuro em 30 40 anos vai haver
uma fusão entre o mal sucedido modelo
socialista e agora também percebido como
mal sucedido modelo capitalista acho que
aqui ninguém duvida que esse modelo não
tá bacana não tá rolando e dessa fusão
vai surgir a sociedade do
compartilhamento em que a criação
passará a ser global
isso já tá rolando ea produção passará a
ser local
imagine o seguinte cenário em que estou
aqui junto é com um indiano um italiano
e juntos e desenvolve o produto e criar
juntos nesse produto na hora de produzir
tem duas possibilidades ou a gente
reproduz localmente este produto cada um
faz a sua grana ou a gente monta uma
indústria com a pouca estrutura de
distribuição e logística de marketing do
sul e paraná
eu tenho a impressão de que o primeiro
caminho ele vai ser mais interessante
pra mim ela está apostando muito nisso e
acho que é importante que todos reflitam
também um pouco sobre isso
por trás desse movimento de mudança de
comportamento tem um movimento maker
ele atua com uma base transversal da
construção dessa mudança de sentimento
de paradigma de quebra de paradigmas que
nos apontam para um futuro diferente no
futuro e que não só em que a gente vai
além daquela cultura do faça você mesmo
e vai para a cultura do façamos juntos
têm que se juntar para resolver os
problemas da nossa cidade e para
identificar oportunidades de negócio e
não basta a gente se juntarem tem que
juntar gente
diferente se você pega um time com três
arquitetos que pega outro time com um
arquiteto um biólogo e engenheiro
eletrônico
fatalmente o segundo time vai gerar um
produto muito mágico fatalmente o
segundo tempo vai gerar um produto
inovador e se você adicionar esse
segundo time
o usuário o cliente o cidadão aí esse
produto vai ser mágico porque ele vai
refletir o real desejo das pessoas é
sobre isso que a gente está falando
desejo pessoas cidade
será que a cidade inteligente é aquela
que tem sensores hardwares que têm
tecnologia embarcada em todos os
sentidos
eu acho que não porque se fosse simples
assim se fosse só jogar a tecnologia à
educação já estava resolvida no mundo
nos anos 90
encheram a sala de computadores
aí chega chegou no ano de 2010 agora a
gente vai resolver tudo é só um tablet
no lugar dos computadores
sinceramente para mim educação no mundo
continuam merda não é tecnologia que
resolve os problemas tecnologia
ferramenta o que resolve os problemas é
gente o que a gente faz hoje é juntar
gente a gente vem desenvolvendo um
trabalho super bacana
em recife uma pesquisa em que a gente
está desenvolvendo uma luminária para
pedestres
tem muita coisa que parece baixa quando
a gente vai observar porque as calçadas
da cidade são escuras porque a
iluminação pública voltada pra a rua
está voltada para os carros ea violência
termina acontecendo de uma forma maior
do que deveria porque as calçadas estão
escuras
então a gente resolveu criar uma
luminária que não é não tem nada de
fantástico do ponto de vista tecnológico
voltada para a calçada com o ka placa de
captura de energia solar sensores e que
fosse possível ser construída instalada
pela própria como
idade a gente tá no início dessa
pesquisa
eu já consigo visualizar comdec isso vai
dar
eu já tô vendo uma comunidade de recife
ou de qualquer lugar do brasil e do
mundo em que aquela liderança
comunitária vai juntar todo mundo na rua
na praça vai dizer gente acabei de
baixar o projeto lado fábio recife na
internet tem os tutoriais tem os manuais
têm tudo
já combinei a igreja vai entrar um
pouquinho o bug fulano vai entrar um
pouquinho a mercearia vai entrar um
pouquinho
dona zefinha vai fazer a feijoada para a
gente comemorar depois que a gente fizer
todo o nosso trabalho e é o seguinte o
final de semana todo mundo na rua para
fazer um mutirão porque a gente vai
construir novas luminárias ea gente nem
vai estar lá e vai fazer manutenção
delas quando isso acontecer aí vou tomar
uma honra porque vai estar provado que
essa teoria que pra gente ainda hoje é
base de estudos é possível virar
realidade
e a gente está trabalhando com
construção de realidade tem uma outra
experiência bacana que a gente está
rodando que eu acho que vocês vão achar
bem interessantes
a gente começou a rodar uma experiência
em belo jardim e uma cidade a 180
quilômetros de recife mais ou menos ea
gente juntou a galera da cidade à
comunidade tiveram vários momentos de
pesquisas e entrevistas mas ele pegou um
final de semana específico
hoje temos 26 pessoas desta comunidade
para junto com oito arquitetos com a
equipe do fábio recife do instituto
conceição moura a gente descobrir a
solução pra criar uma nova ocupação para
essa pressa área de 6 mil metros
quadrados no centro da cidade
e aí veja que bacana esse projeto já em
curso ainda tá certo mas eu queria jogar
uma bolinha pra vocês do que vai
acontecer a partir dela é mágico esse
momento que a gente vive e que se
acredita cada vez mais no poder
transformador das pessoas
buscar e encontrar diante das
alternativas que a comunidade traz para
discussão como esses espaços podem se
articular e ajudar no desenvolvimento
das pessoas e da cidade como um todo as
pessoas cada vez mais vem ocupar o
espaço da cidade as praças parques e
espera um clubbing com o lactec
ela tem vários bailes de carnaval
festival do shopping que seja de fato
esse espaço de convivência mas que seja
também um espaço de memória a 10 num
lugar onde tenha a ciência também a
família fazer piquenique com minhas
amigas num lugar seguro é show de bancos
a pessoa enfrentar
então eu queria agora que vocês se
fizesse novamente essa pergunta como as
pessoas vão interagir com as cidades em
eu tenho certeza que vai ser muito
diferente do que muita gente vem falando
por aí
mas para que esse futuro aconteça
do jeito que eu quero do jeito que eu
trouxe aqui pra vocês é preciso juntar
muita gente eu estou construindo a
cidade que eu quero e vocês